In January of 2021,
Alaska was on the cusp
of the most highly
anticipated vaccine launch
in 50 years, the COVID vaccine.
So as the state began
to roll out shots
to senior citizens
age 65 and above,
the hottest ticket in town was
a COVID-19 vaccine appointment.
So when a batch of
appointments would come online,
those would be snatched up
within hours or sometimes
even minutes.
And back in those
days, everybody
needed an online appointment.
You couldn't just walk in and
get your COVID-19 vaccine.
So it's a really exciting time.
But we found out pretty
quickly that the website
the state was using to
get people signed up
was not working well
for senior citizens.
It was hiding the appointments
in several pages of results.
It was made for health
care professionals working
on desktop computers,
but wasn't working
for people on the phones.
The maps were distorted.
It's showing the
Sacramento County
Jail instead of the Anchorage
Health Department here.
And so we started to
hear from senior citizens
that they were struggling,
that they were not
making it through the
appointment registration
process.
And so at this really
critical juncture,
the senior citizens are
starting to contact us
and saying that there are some
are at the cusp of actually
giving up.
And at this really important
moment of the pandemic,
senior citizens are frustrated.
The state is frustrated.
And I'm frustrated,
especially when
I learned that there's no
changes and no improvements
that can come to the
website anytime soon.
But I knew that
there must be a way
to improve this
website experience,
and I knew I had
to at least try.
So my name is Ben Matheson.
I work for the
Anchorage Innovation
Team in Anchorage, Alaska.
We're a small team inside city
government that uses data,
human centered design and
technology to solve problems.
So we try to improve
the lives of residents,
solve problem with city
departments and save money.
So today I'm going
to tell you about how
we built a vaccine finder
for the state of Alaska
in one week using R
and hope to show you
how R is a great tool
for rapid prototyping
and rapid building of products.
And after this, I hope
that you can better
appreciate how you have the
tools and abilities to really
make some cool custom,
rapid products.
And so before we started
building anything
we wanted to validate
there was a problem
and find out exactly
what this problem was.
So we got on the phone
with senior citizens
as they were trying to
sign up for their vaccines.
And we found out a few things.
One is that they are struggling
through a complex website.
We learned that
they're struggling
with some pretty complicated
health questions that show up
in these vaccine
registration systems
and also learning that the adult
children sometimes of seniors
are the ones who are actually
signing up for appointments.
And so we tried to narrow
the problem a little bit to,
how can we help Anchorage
senior citizens who
want their vaccine really
quickly find that appointment
so that they can
get their vaccine?
And so before we started
building anything big,
we wanted to do a
no budget build,
an MVP, a minimum
viable product.
So in this case, what is
the smallest, fastest,
quickest thing that we
can make that proves
that there is value?
Get it into the hands
of people and see
whether we're
helping the problem
or if we need to go in a
totally different direction.
And so this was literally
Friday night project.
It's Friday night
in early January,
and I picked up the
tools that I use
when I want to make
something fast and easy.
And not easy.
But I picked up dplyr.
I use stringr and
lubridate and we're
trying to capture vaccine
appointments as they come
online and as they disappear.
And we learn pretty quickly
that there's no API coming.
There's no programmatic
access to vaccine appointments
in Anchorage.
So it's time to scrape.
So we use rvest to scrape
the vaccine web pages.
And anybody who's ever used
web scraper knows that
it's like trying to
create order from chaos.
You know, you find a div that
appears to have the information
that you're looking for.
You know, it's border gray
200 is the div that we want.
Here we go.
Grab that div and
extract the text from it.
And from that text
we try to turn that
into structured data
that serves our needs.
So rip it apart, mutate,
modify, put it back together
and make structured
data out of this text.
So we're scraping, we're
able to capture that data.
But then it's time for
a really quick front
end of how do you discover
vaccine appointments?
And because this
website was a reaction
to an overly
complicated website,
we wanted to go with something
super simple, super fast, super
lightweight.
And so I went with
an HTML table.
So on the left is
the prototype that
came together after a few
hours on a Friday night.
It's a web scraping service
that scrapes every 60 seconds
to try to find those
appointments as they come up,
as they disappear.
And we show those in a really
simple format no filtering,
no menus, no maps, no anything.
It's how do you really quickly
find those actual vaccine
appointments?
And then it's time to test.
So we've got this
very prototype website
and we sent it to people who
are working on the vaccine call
center.
It's a team of about 40 people
who spend all day on the phone
with senior citizens
trying to help them sign up
for appointments.
And they're able to give us
some really good feedback.
They're able to see
if it's helping.
And it did help.
They were able to use
it as a power tool.
This was the vaccine
call center's power tool
that we tried out and then
something else happened
in that this website
started to be passed around
between people.
And it's not a real website.
It's not a real product.
But over the course of a
weekend, all of a sudden
there's hundreds of people
using this website and signing up
for appointments.
And we're hearing
back and people
are having a good experience.
So we know that there's
something there,
but it turned into
an unexpected launch.
We've got this product,
this prototype,
but the state liked it.
They wanted to use it.
And so we developed a
really quick partnership
with the state health
departments, the Anchorage Health
Department and the
emergency operation center.
And nobody from Alaska
can do a presentation
without a map of Alaska.
But I just want to clarify.
I work for the
City of Anchorage.
So we're the biggest
city in Alaska, about 40%
of the state's population.
But what the state
wants to do is
to use this scraping
based vaccine
finder for the entire state.
So they want to use it
in Fairbanks and Juneau
and Ketchikan and Kodiak.
And I'd say that's awesome.
That's great.
But we have to scramble here.
And so over the
course of the week,
we cleaned up the scraper.
We made it real by
buying a domain.
And about one week
later, we launched.
So we had an Alaska statewide
vaccine finder tool.
It's what I showed before,
but basically cleaned up.
It's appointments that you
can find by location, address,
vaccine type.
It's text above on the
phone that works well.
And that's it.
That's that's what we
generated and that's
what we started using.
And so over the course
of January and February,
we use this for
things like signing up
people for these
big mass vaccination
clinics at a basketball
arena or when we launched
drive-through clinics
at hockey arenas.
We sign people up
through this website.
So that's a lot of fun.
And we got some good feedback.
People, people were able
to use this to connect
to their appointments.
And this tool was doing
what we hoped it was doing.
But it wasn't always
straightforward,
it wasn't always easy.
And things definitely don't
always go according to plan.
So on March 9th,
2021, we got word
that the governor was going
to make a big announcement.
Alaska is going to be the
first state in the country
to go fully open for everybody.
Everybody age 16
and above would be
able to get their
vaccine appointments.
So at 4:44 p.m., I had to
send this message to my boss.
The website was down.
We had some weird data
come across the scraper
at the moment that we
were expecting the biggest
surge in traffic, maybe
the highest amount
of interest over the course
of the entire rollout.
I have to deal with this, but
I was able to filter it out,
keep it online and was
really happy that we could
put this banner up
saying everybody aged 16
and older can now get
their vaccine in Alaska.
So we stayed online throughout
that pretty busy day.
And over the course
of this project,
we didn't have the
most stable website.
We didn't have the
fanciest website.
fastest website.
But our measure success
was how fast could we
adapt to everything,
adapt to new eligibility,
adapt to new data,
adapt to new pharmacies,
adapt to new requirements.
That's exactly
what we had to do.
This this vaccine rollout was
one where Alaska was first
and we couldn't
copy anybody else.
We couldn't copy California
or New York, or Washington,
but we kind of had to
make it up as we go.
If we could copy, we would.
But we just couldn't.
And some projects, the timelines
aren't what you expect.
So in early January, we heard
a really optimistic timeline
that vaccines will be open
by the summer solstice.
So approximately a
six month rollout
of those vaccines
before they open up.
But here it was March 9th, and
it's the Iditarod trail sled
dog race.
And we've got vaccines
rolling out to everybody.
So this whole project move
even faster than we ever really
had expected.
And we rode those waves
throughout January and February
as we opened up to
younger people as we opened
up to new eligibility.
And we got something for
Alaska, some major traffic,
we'd see 20, 40,000
pages on a given day.
And for this scraping
based website
that has no backup and no
team besides myself, my boss,
we got a million page views.
We connected the thousands of
Alaskans to their appointments,
and it served as the Alaska
statewide vaccine finder tool
for many months.
And on a personal note, I got
my very first piece of fan mail
for an R project, and I
definitely sent this to my boss
as soon as I got that email.
But as we moved from out
of those really crazy days
of the early pandemic,
we want to turn this
into something more stable.
I'd spend enough time trying
to fix a scraper at 9 PM or 6
a.m., and one of
the big changes was
that we started with
one major data source.
And that's scraping this
system called Prepmod.
But all of a sudden
we're bringing
in all sorts of other data.
We've got pharmacy APIs, we've
got some open source project
that brings in pharmacy chains.
Vaccines.gov came
on board and we
access some of that CDC data.
And then all of a sudden
this simple project
turns into kind of
a complex project
with six different opportunities
for things to break.
And what I was
definitely overdue to do
was to turn all these into
modules so that when something
breaks, you can turn it off.
When something needs
to be troubleshooted,
you can target that in
its own individual file,
in its own individual function.
And it made it from
a brittle website
into a less brittle website.
I also tried to bring
in more error handling
errors would break the website
in the early days for sure.
So I brought in a bunch
more try catch statements.
So that you can run a statement
and if it successfully
executes you get
your data back.
But if and when
that error comes,
we can still return
some valid data.
We can still keep the rest
of the sources online.
And we don't break
the system just
because those errors did come.
For automation,
we really wanted to
track appointments
24/7 because they were really
going fast in those early days.
And so we wanted to
scrape every single minute
to see how close we could keep
up with vaccine appointments.
And the way I did this was
with a Heroku R Buildpack
and a Heroku Cron
job where I basically
ran one script every 10 minutes
and then in those 10 minutes
I scraped several times.
So seven or 10 times every
10 minutes we scraped
and we scraped and we
scraped and scraped
and about 5 million
HTML pages, I
think we scraped before
we finally moved off
of that, that scraper.
So that prototype
turned into something
that got used quite a bit.
We also had to adapt to
the complexity that came up
throughout the process of this.
If you may remember,
there is a lot of phases.
There's phase one b, tier
one, phase one, a tier three,
and we got a lot of
requests to have information
like this on the website, and we
don't like too much complexity
and we're pretty militant
about having simple information
as much as possible.
So the way that we did this
on the front end was we
kept the appointments
above the fold,
as they say, so
appointments up high,
but we radically simplified
the eligibility information
and kind of had it
slightly hidden.
But we kept the scope of this
as narrow as we can to, here's
where you find
your appointments.
And then more complexity
came in that all of a sudden,
we've got a lot of vaccine
appointments and supplies
at a certain point, and it's
turning into a big list that
needs some management.
And because we don't want
to add complicated menus
and we wanted this
to work really
well on phones,
what we did was just
little, little HTML
buttons that allows
you to search this table
for the city or region.
And there's a lot
of string a lot
of string searching
going on in this.
So that was our strategy for
dealing with that complexity.
So what have I learned
throughout this experience?
One is that there is a really
subtle power to creating
an MVP, to creating a demo.
So if we had asked in advance
permission to do this website,
we would have encountered
a lot of reasons to say no.
It's like, what's
your budget, what's
the plan, what's
your backup plan?
Who's the staff
in charge of this?
But when you put something
in the hands of people
where they can interact
with it and break
through all those barriers,
there's really a lot of magic
to it.
And these prototypes,
in our case,
they're not they're not pretty.
They're text on a phone.
But sometimes a prototype,
just a proof of
concept, can sometimes
blow people's minds just enough
to break through and make
progress on projects.
There's also some
secret value in building
your own data set.
And in this case, we were
really the only people
scraping and
aggregating appointments
across the state of Alaska.
And because we wanted to track
how many appointments there
were, we had the
tools to do that.
And I displayed how
many appointments
were available at any given
moment throughout the day.
And this is basically
out of curiosity
because we wanted to see
how fast things were going.
But at some point we learned
that the state health
department was actually
watching this number
and actually using that
number to make decisions
on when it's time to
open up eligibility
or when it's time to
make some changes.
So when you build that data set,
sometimes you have the ability
to find value and find
unexpected value in places that
you didn't
intend.
So R is a great
prototyping tool,
especially with all of
you who love R and have
spent some time with it.
This project was a
series of data frames
that basically would be created,
updated, modified, and then
destroyed
every every single minute
is what we would do.
And because I'm comfortable
manipulating data frames,
that's what I did.
And it's ultimately this data
frame that took a lot of work.
But that data frame
turns into the product.
It's the world's simplest
database that is JSON or CSV,
but that turns into
the actual product.
So if you have that
ability to work fast in R,
you're really set up well
to create prototypes.
And in some projects,
if this project
had a different
timeline and we knew
we had months to
work on this, I may
have used something more
traditional like Node.js
or Python or something
more standard to build out
a web service and a website
and maybe some React
or something.
But this is a project
where the timeline was now,
and it's a timeline of the
prototype is now the product.
So in those projects where speed
and flexibility matter most,
I think R is absolutely
your superpower.
So if you've put in the reps and
have that ability to work fast,
you're in a really
great place to do that.
If you haven't put in the
reps, you're doing it.
You're doing it right now.
And I think that you
all should appreciate
that you have the skills,
the abilities and absolutely
the tools to really quickly
make custom software or custom
analyses or models.
And your ability to
do that fast, I think,
can sometimes be a huge
advantage in projects.
So if a computer is like
a bicycle for the mind,
I have to think of R as like
the electric cargo bike.
It's something where you
can help a lot of people.
You can do absolutely
anything with it
and you can go fast and
really have a lot of fun.
So thank you very much.